>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> NICOLE CHUNG: M.T. Anderson he
writes a bunch of awesome books
for a bunch of different age groups.
His book "Feed" was a finalist for
the National Book Award and his book
"The Astonishing Life of Octavian
Nothing, Trader to the Nation,
Volume 1" won the 2006 National
Book Award for Young People.
His newest book is "Landscape with
Invisible Hand" which is a satire
of ardent truth in the
mist of colonization.
So, without any further
ado, M.T. Anderson.
[ Applause ]
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Thanks so much.
It's great to be here.
Thank you all for coming.
So, yeah, my name is M. T.
Anderson, and what I'm going to talk
about today in connection
with my fourth coming book,
which will be out in
just a couple days,
"Landscape with Invisible
Hand," is the American landscape
and how the American landscape can
be transformed through imagination.
So, I grew up in a small town in
Massachusetts, the Town of Stowe.
It was a very small,
boring American town.
We were actually proud of how boring
it was because like that was almost,
it was almost iconic in how dull
it was, you know what I mean?
Like, so we had the typical
white congregational church.
We had the little, you know
the red Carnegie era library.
Like even the bullies
were like totally.
The bullies who used to beat me
up were totally like old-fashion.
Like there was no cyber
bullying then, they were doing
like all the same things they'd done
to like Puritan kid back
in the 16th century.
You know, like the monkey
bite, all that kind of thing.
You know, the real classic.
So, growing up in this town, I loved
it there, I loved how dull it was.
And you know, at the same time of
course, I always dreamed of kind
of far-flung bizarre
destinations and adventures.
All around the world, you know.
For example, Conan the Barbarian,
who I based a lot of
my adult life on.
You can't tell, but beneath this
shirt, I'm pure barbarian brawn.
So, I always wanted to be the kind
of writer who would travel the world
and see sort of these unusual
places and write about them.
And to some extent, I
guess I have done that,
except I'm somewhat hampered by the
fact that I'm a terrible traveler.
For example, I have all
sorts of gastric distresses.
So, here I am on top of
the Himalayas thinking
about how far it is to
a bathroom [laughter].
And I've actually been, I
have so many food allergies
that I have actually
been hospitalized
in every continent
except Antarctica.
And I haven't been there, but
I'm sure that once I get there;
here I am being hospitalized
in France,
for example, in the Pyrenees.
The funny thing about being;
so, I was following the route
of the Albigensian crusades
through the Pyrenees.
And I went to a concert
of some medieval music
in an old medieval castle.
Which was great, except the tuning
of the instruments was so bad I had
like anaphylactic shock as a result.
So, they had to call an ambulance
and things, I was puffing up.
And I was sitting there, and my
girlfriend said to me you know,
you really look bad, you
need to get out of here.
And I was like, well I can't because
like, it's the middle of a song.
I'll wait until the end of the song.
But those medieval songs are
like 500 freaking verses.
So, by the time that the song ended,
I had like pustules all over me.
And so, I stood up and in typical
fashion, like, I mean I know a bit
of French, but I panicked and
so instead of saying to them,
because everyone stopped and looked
at me, because there were only
like 20 people in the audience.
And so, everyone stopped and looked
at me and instead of saying to them,
you know, I'm sorry I am sick,
which is what I was trying to say,
of course I said to them, I'm
sorry, I'm evil [laughter].
And then I left.
I can't hang around for this.
So, I'm going to start
smoking soon, like a,
you know demon possessed
person at a church.
Anyway, so, oh, the other thing
is you know, it was very hard
to explain to the EMTs,
like to ask them questions,
because I didn't know in
French any medical terms.
So, instead of saying like
how is my blood pressure I had
to say things like
is my blood strong?
It's sounds like Voltaire
or something.
So, anyway.
So, but nonetheless, I have
travelled the world despite this,
which is how I've had anaphylactic
reactions in every continent.
So, you know, I have been to
Katmandu and I've travelled all
over the place in France, as
I said following the route
of the Albigensian crusades.
I've gone to haunted castles
and to ancient Chinese cities,
ancient Tibetan monasteries.
And in fact, with a historian friend
of mine, I went into the far west
of China, the Xinjiang
Uyghur Autonomous Region.
I'm so sorry that you have
to try to translate that.
Right [laughter] in far western
China, searching for the temple
of a rat God, which we
did eventually find.
And I have been to
exorcism ceremonies in Java
and all this kind of thing.
And yet, and yet, the
strangest thing
out of all these travels
was not any of the things
that I've talked about, but coming
back to my home in Cambridge,
and then looking at it with new
eyes and wondering for example,
why is it that the guy down
the street is building a large
weaponized mechanical
spider [laughter]?
Like, it turned out
after all of that
that the strangest things I've
seen are at home, you know?
I went to upstate New York
and discovered that the town
with the Jell-O factory in
it is right next to the town
with the Cool-Whip
factory [laughter].
Upstate New York is an
incredibly weird place.
They were like, this town, there
were rifts opening up in the ground
that smelled like sulfur.
And people were just like, oh
yeah, it's really bad today.
And I was like, the apocalypse
is happening, don't you notice?
So, and this is what I
think is really important is
that we should seek out the stories
that are all right around us.
America is full of
these bizarre stories.
And that is where all of you can
be looking for your material.
For the stories that you want to
tell about the places that you live,
to celebrate wherever
it is you live.
Your small, boring town.
So, I eventually wrote a novel for
young kids, called "Jasper Dash
and the Flame Pits of Delaware."
And, the idea of this book was
to actually kind of like take all
of the stupid things we
say about other countries
when we write adventure novels,
like, oh, in South America
and Africa there are dinosaurs.
And that kind of thing, all these
sort of like fictitious things
that we make up about other
countries and instead apply them
to a place in America
that I knew that myself,
and almost no one else
had ever been to,
that is to say Delaware [laughter].
I mean, and you know,
many of you are from DC,
you know that the only reason
anyone ever goes to Delaware,
correct me if I'm wrong is because
if you're going to New York you have
to pass through the corner of
Delaware and those jerks charge you
like $6 for 3.5 minutes
of road time, right?
So, this book therefore, is about
some explorers who go into the heart
of deepest Delaware, a place where
people have not been for many,
many years because of the
exorbitant interstate tolls.
And they discover that it's this
land of wonder with dinosaurs
and lizard people and
all this kind of thing.
So, and in it, I actually said, I
have a note that said, you know,
please we at this publishing
company want
to make sure we get all
the details correct.
And so, if you are from Delaware,
or have been there or know someone
from Delaware and find that
this is not your experience,
please immediately write a letter
to, you know, correct these errors.
And so, then I gave the
address for the Governor
of Delaware's mansion [laughter].
Because it's his problem, I
mean you know, it's not mine.
I don't live there.
So, anyway I got a great letter
from the Governor of Delaware,
which is the only time a state
governor has ever called me Buster.
And he told me, look he said,
stop corrupting the children
of our state, come down and
visit and I will show you
that our state is very, very normal.
It's very, very typical.
It is not a land of wonders,
a land that time forgot,
or chose specifically
not to remember.
So, I did go down to
Delaware and met the governor
and he was a super nice guy, this is
Governor Markell, but I said to him
at the time, I was like, Dude,
and you know only the adults
in the audience will unfortunately
remember this period which is
about what, would this be, ten years
ago maybe, I was like, my friend,
you invited me down here to convince
me that Delaware is a boring state.
And yet, one of your, a woman
who is running for Congress
from your state has had to begin;
you see where I'm going with this;
has had to begin her campaign
ads with, "I am not a witch."
I mean what other state has
a witchcraft problem among
their senators.
So, anyway, and then on the way home
from this very meeting I was
driving up route 1 in Delaware.
And suddenly there are all
these helicopters overhead,
shining lights everywhere.
And it turned out that on the
highway that I was driving on,
I was the last car to get
through because a sniper was
in an apartment building
shooting at the highway,
and they were closing
down the highway.
So, I wrote to him and I
was like, well governor,
I guess I've only been shot
at a couple times in my life,
and one of them was in your state.
So, as I say, think
about all the things
that are actually tremendously
bizarre in the place that you are.
And the way that those
stories connect
with the history of your town.
So, for example, I talk to a
lot of kids about the stories,
the myths they have about
their town and their state.
And for example, they told
me that there was a myth
that the Dupont family had a
bunch; who are from Delaware
and have beautifully funded a
lot of the stuff in that state,
because the Dupont family had these
sort of children who would come
out deformed as a result of
chemical contact who were all kept
in a particular house
off in the woods.
And you know people
would got to the house,
you know for their dates and stuff.
But the neat thing about
that is that in a weird way,
even through the medium of
the horrific, of the bizarre,
or the ghost story in a sense.
You get the real history of the
place as well, rolled into that.
Places have these identities
that extend from what is real
into fantasy, into our dream lives.
And I think that that's
really amazing.
That's something to be celebrated.
You know, once again, you
know when I; oh yeah so,
the American landscape
is, these are pictures
from 19th century American
landscape painters.
American landscape
painting is supposed to be
about describing a place, exactly.
And what that place looks like.
And yet, at the same time,
it's also about what you build
out of those images of your
landscape in your imagination.
All of the castles in the air,
as it were, that you build,
out of what you see around you.
And you know, once again to
return to my friend Conan here,
this does not look like an
American landscape, and yet,
the guy who created Conan
was a kind of a sad sap,
Robert E. Howard, living in Texas.
And he says that when he
created his land of Samaria
where Conan is supposed to be a
barbarian, he actually based it
on the area that he was in in Texas.
So, even though he's
writing supposedly
about Europe during the
Dark Ages, in a way,
it also is an American landscape.
And we should not also forget
that Conan the Barbarian was,
in fact the Governor of
California [laughter].
So, yeah, I look, I got home
to my apartment in Cambridge,
Mass and I look at this
bizarre tree that someone,
this sort of Charlie Brown like
tree that someone planted, and sure,
it is in a sense, there's something
that can be transformed about it.
I mean during the day, it
looks like a sort of Han period
like sleeve dancer or something from
ancient China, and then at night,
you see the same tree and
it's transformed into say,
the slender man, you
know what I mean?
All of these things around us,
remind us of the wonders that are
to be found right at home.
And there's a beautiful quotation
by T.S. Elliot about this, which is,
"We shall not cease
from exploration,
in the end of all our exploring
will be to arrive where we started
and know the place
for the first time."
That to me, seems like
the essence for one thing,
of traveling that you go
away, and you learn in fact
where it is that you are from.
You learn to recognize your home.
Because when we live, when
we don't leave our home,
we stop seeing our home.
We don't notice anything
about our hose even anymore.
We stop seeing the people we live,
we take everything for granted.
And it's not until you go away to
a distant hillside and look back
at your town, that you can see
your town for the first time,
and realize, oh that's how it works,
that's what it's actually like.
And I think that literature
does the same thing.
Literature takes us just far
enough away from what we know
that then we can look
back at what we know
and see it for the first time.
See it with new eyes.
And that, I think is the
real power of literature.
So, I'm going to talk just
briefly, I'm going to;
how many minutes do I have left?
I have 15 minutes left?
Over 15 minutes left.
Okay, so I'm just going to talk
very briefly about the books that;
some of the books I've written
and how I feel I have tried
to transform sort of American
places in these books.
"Landscape with Invisible Hand"
which will be out in a few days,
is a satirical science
fiction novel, for example,
about a kid who is a
landscape painter trying
to paint American landscapes
in the wake
of an alien colonization
of the earth.
So, the story is told entirely
through descriptions
of his paintings.
As he kind of records both
the spread of this sort
of alien infiltration and also
the dissolution of his family,
the difficulties he's
having with his own family.
So, obviously in this case, I
really am very openly talking
about landscape and it being
transformed, whereas "Feed,"
which is perhaps my best-known novel
is a book about the far future,
actually not too far,
like 2050 or something,
where everyone has a
chip in their head.
A sort of internet chip directly in
their head that allows them access
to this whole sort of
world of telecommunication,
but at the same time,
keeps everyone awash
in a constant flurry
of advertisements.
So, once again, in this case what
I'm trying to do is create a kind
of a science fiction allegory
that then shows you the
world we already live in.
I don't care, in a sense,
when I was writing this,
which was a long time ago now, I
didn't care about the technology
and whether we would really
have chips in our head.
Though it does appear we will.
I mean, but we all have that to
look forward to, but nonetheless,
what I really was trying
to do instead was to say,
this is what I feel right now.
Right now, I already have the voice
of advertising ringing
through my head.
As a teen, I already had
advertisers saying to me,
this is what you should want, this
is what you should dream about,
this is who you should want to be.
So, once again using the kind
of the science fiction image
to take you away from
what you know just enough
so you could see something about
the world that we live in right now.
In my books "The Norumbegan
Quartet," this is a series of books
for some of the younger kids
that are actually set in Vermont,
a place I know and love very much.
However, turning it into a kind
of a mythological landscape,
with an ancient race that is
hiding there playing a kind
of a magical game.
So, once again this thing
of like taking a landscape
and transforming it.
And then, finally, my book "The
Pox Party," which the full title is
"The Astonishing Life of Octavian
Nothing, Traitor to the Nation,
Volume 1, The Pox Party"
and " The Astonishing Life
of Octavian Nothing, Traitor
to the Nation, Volume 2,
The Kingdom on the Waves."
These books are actually
set in Boston,
another place that I know and love.
But in the 18th century.
And the idea is that
they should seem almost
like gothic fantasy novels
or something at first.
Because you don't realize
what it is you're looking at.
And my whole idea was after
you start to recognize,
oh wait a second, this is Boston,
this is right before the revolution,
by that time, I want the
reader to feel like the history
that we know too well, that
history of the revolution,
suddenly you can access it again
and see it through new eyes.
So, in each of these cases, my
goal is to take something known,
a place that we know, a
story that we know too well,
and transform it enough that
we can see that story again.
So, I just want to say to all
of you who are young writers,
or even not young writers, just
people who like to tell stories
to your friends, don't forget the
strangeness that is all around you
and how to grasp that, and realize
that the place you live,
is some place special.
And we need you to tell
the stories of that place,
we need you to tell us all
about where you're from.
So, that you can take us out of
who we are and show us again who,
as a nation, you know who we
are and what we can become.
So, thank you very much and I'll
answer questions if there are any.
[ Applause ]
Otherwise, I'll just stand
up here super awkwardly.
I could do a little like
music song you know.
Do, do, do, do, do.
Do, do, do, do.
Oh, thank God.
>> I'll shoot for one.
Given the fact that you
work with various settings,
various time periods, are you, in
your writing, your initial writer,
are you more of a panzer
or a plotter?
Are you a major outliner in your?
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Okay, for
those of you who are not writers,
the terms he's using, thank you for
the question, panzer and plotter are
like do you do it by
the seat of pants?
Like, you don't know
where you're heading into,
you just start writing the
book, or are you a plotter?
Are you someone who
sets out every single,
you know event ahead of time.
And I've done both is the answer.
So, for "Feed" for
example, I had no idea
where that story was going to go.
But in other things, I've set
out like every single scene
and have known ahead of time.
And as a piece of advice to your
writers, I think books that are more
about character and slow internal
development, might I mean I found
that it's easier for them
if I do not know what is
going to go on ahead of time.
But books that are about external,
you know events, and adventure,
those it really helps to know
what's going to go on ahead of time,
because that way you can lay
in clues, you can set things
up so it's satisfying and
has that satisfying snap.
Because you know you always
hate those like mystery novels,
where you feel like they kind of
made it up on the fly, you know?
So, yeah, so that's
what I would say.
And then I've also done nonfiction
stuff like "Symphony for the City
of the Dead" which is a nonfiction
book about the siege of Leningrad,
where obviously, I
had to do, you know,
years of research ahead of time.
And it is nonfiction so
I didn't have a choice
about what was going to happen.
You know what I mean?
Believe me if it had been up to me,
things would have ended
much happier [laughter].
Yes?
>> Are there any fantasy worlds
in books you've read
that you really enjoy?
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Are there
fantasy worlds in books I've read,
yeah thank you, that
I've really enjoyed.
Absolutely, in fact when
I was probably your age,
I used to wish that, like you
know those gateway fantasies,
where like you start in this work
and then you end up in that world
and suddenly you have magic
powers and all that kind of thing.
Which I totally wanted
that to happen to me.
And you know at the
end of those books,
you know they always have someone
come back, you know to this world.
And that was always a letdown for
me, I was like, dude, our world?
Why do you want to go back
to the world of like Stop
and Stops and you know, Weetabix?
I was like no, stay
in the fantasy world.
We have super powers you moron.
So, yeah, I absolutely, but
they would have been different
from my generation,
I'm afraid than yours.
So, for example "Harry Potter" came
out when I was a youngish adult.
So, for me, it was more people
like "The Earthsea" books
by Ursula Le Guin, which
I really, really loved.
That kind of thing, yeah.
>> So, can everybody hear me?
Okay. So, I read your "Symphony
for the City of the Dead."
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Oh, great.
>> And I loved it, but I was
wondering why you chose nonfiction,
and Russia, and the 1940s instead
of something more American
and more close to home.
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Okay.
All right, great.
So, the question is why did I?
So, I'm glad you asked
about this book
because I have some slides
related to it [laughter].
Not a plant.
But, so yeah, so this is a
book which is about the siege
of Leningrad during World War
II, which is in fact one of the,
I'm sorry, it is the longest
siege in recorded human history.
And it was a terrifying siege.
The Germans surrounded the Russian
City of Leningrad for several years.
And there was no food,
there was no water.
More people died in the defense
of; the whole city was sort
of transformed into a
military camp, over the years.
And more people died in
Leningrad, or defending Leningrad
than have died in all
American wars, ever.
So, that is to say like Americans
in any war, if you clump all
of those together,
it is still fewer.
I'm sorry, I know that
I'm not speaking well.
But it is fewer dead
than died in this siege.
And in the middle of this,
there's this composer there who's
writing a symphony about this
as he's working as a
fireman standing on the roof
of the conservatory trying
to put out incendiary bombs.
So, that was kind of the material.
Frankly, the reason I decided to
make it nonfiction was the story was
so dramatic, and so bizarre, like
all of the details were so weird,
that I felt like if I turned it into
fiction it's going to lose its edge,
because no one will
really believe it.
I have to insist on the fact
that it is not fiction for people
to believe it, because, and
this comes to the second part
of your very excellent question,
why did I choose a Russian topic
and a World War II topic.
The second part of it is that we
do not know, or we do not think
about that war in the way that
people elsewhere in the world do.
The Russians, for example, do
not, Russian historians don't talk
about World War II in
the same way we do.
They talk about something
called "The Great Patriotic War"
which for them starts in
1941, that is to say later
than we see the Second
World War starting.
It has a totally different
narrative associated with it.
So, I wanted once again
to say, this is something
that we take for granted.
We think, oh, you know the Second
World War we know our stories
of heroism that often are connected
with our own families'
stories of heroism.
My family for example,
fought in the Philippines.
So, I think of it very much in terms
of a Pacific theater, or you know,
we think in terms of western
Europe, or North Africa
where American troops
were largely involved.
But at the same time, most of the
deaths in that war on our side,
on the allied side
were Russian citizens.
Because more Soviets died
in that war than people
of all other nations combined.
And then the Chinese, who are often
forgotten entirely in all of this.
So, as a result, I was like,
no I want to write about this,
which is in fact, tremendously
important to the way a lot of people
around the world see this war
and is still affecting
Russian policy today.
If you look at the way that Putin
and the Russians understand global
politics, it's directly tied
to their sense of things
after that war,
and of trying to create
buffer states
and protections for themselves.
So, anyway my point is it's
super important to open our eyes
to what's there and to say, I'm
not going to accept the story
that I've always been told.
Instead I'm going to
ask questions about it.
I'm going to find out all the things
that are sort of the secret truths
that really make this world run.
So, I guess that's my answer.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
I don't know who's supposed
to ask a question next.
>> So, whenever you're writing
your books, do you write them
with these allegories and these
symbols in mind, or do they come
as a result of you
writing them down?
>> M.T. ANDERSON: I don't know.
Because to me it's not always
about like allegories and symbols,
but just what is it
that I am anxious about.
What is it that I care about.
And that's what comes
out in the writing.
You know what I mean?
So, for example, in "Feed" I kind
of knew in the case of "Feed."
Like, no, there was no question
in my mind that this thing
with the chip in the head
and all that kind of thing,
that that was you know, I totally
thought of that ahead of time.
Like, oh this is a great way
to explore these emotions.
So, you know, it's
different in each case.
But I think by and large, I'm
just writing about what it is
that makes me anxious or angry.
And trying to understand that
anger and that confusion, yeah.
Yes?
>> Do you have a favorite
place to write,
or favorite like music to listen to?
>> M.T. ANDERSON: A favorite what?
>> A favorite place to write?
Oh, okay.
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Yeah.
>> Do you have a favorite place
to write, or like type of music
to listen to where
you get most inspired?
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Absolutely.
Well, both things are true.
So, I mean, I have an office
in my house and that's one
of the best things about
being a writer, right?
I mean I live in New England and
so there is snow all the time,
and so I look out the window and
other people have to commute.
And I'm like oh yeah,
I have to commute too
from my bedroom, down the hall.
It's a great gig.
So, yeah, I mean as far as
listening to music while I write.
I mean I listen to music
very intensely before I write
to get myself into the mood for the
specific scene that I'm going to do.
But I can't listen to
music while I'm writing,
because otherwise I attribute to my
own powers the power of that music.
I'm writing away.
I'm like, oh, man this is so
beautiful man, oh this is genius,
and then I read it the next
day and it's totally boring.
And it's because I was moved by
the music, not by my own writing,
you know, so I have to be careful
of using music itself
while I'm writing, yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Yeah.
Yes?
>> What's the weirdest thing
that's ever happened to you?
[ Laughter ]
>> M.T. ANDERSON: Pardon me?
>> In Delaware?
>> M.T. ANDERSON: In Delaware.
Yeah, when I was, yeah.
That's one of the, I've
only been shot at twice
and that was the worst of the two.
But the weirdest thing?
Well, I'll tell you one neat thing
that just recently happened
which was pretty weird.
So, I recently purchased a haunted
house in the State of Vermont.
They said, it's super
rural there and they're
like well it's really,
really remote.
And extremely cheap because
no one wants to live there,
but it's this 18th century house.
And I was like yeah, what
could possibly go wrong?
So, I moved in and I had heard
that there was an unearthly wailing
that actually happened outside
of one of the upstairs windows.
A child wails in the night.
I'm not a believer
in ghosts by the way.
So, when I, about four days after I
moved in, I was sitting there typing
at around 9:30, and indeed I
heard a totally unearthly wailing
that sounded totally human.
And in fact, I thought it was
someone playing a prank on me.
But it was not.
I'm assuming that it was
some kind of a large mammal.
There are a lot of
them around there.
But I still don't know.
But here's the neat thing,
this is what actually moves it
into the realm of the kind of cool.
I was pulling up the floor
boards to replace them
in the upstairs bedrooms and I found
some letters from the kids who lived
in that house in the 1970s,
who had put these letters
in between the floor
boards to the ghosts.
And what they said, this is so cool.
What they said was,
"Dear Ghost, I love you.
I think you are cute.
I hope your mom buys you a
corgi so you can ride on it.
Do you ice skate?"
Which I though was a great
thing to say to a ghost.
So, what is so beautiful to me as
a novelist about that is the fact
that at once, the girl writing
this wants to comfort the ghost
in some way, which I
think is very beautiful.
And at the same time, what she's
doing is comforting herself in a way
by creating a ghost who is sweet
and can be comforted,
if you see what I mean.
So, it's kind of neat to see that.
And also, to finish I guess, in
this image of how the legendary,
or miraculous, or mythical
transforms the real.
Also under those floor boards,
I found all of these items
that the boy who'd
lived in the house
in the seventies had
dropped in there or whatever.
So, you know.
Like and the whole history
of his childhood was there.
So, I found the like Go Fish
cards from when he was eight.
I found the baseball
cards from when he was 10.
I found the Beatles record
from when he was like 12.
And then I found his porn
stash when he was 15.
Which funnily enough it
actually slid down next
to the giant central fireplace
and was a total like fire hazard.
So, I was like, you know, we are;
they are so lucky this house
didn't burst into flame.
And in a way, it would be
symbolically appropriate
to have this old like Puritan
house burst into flames
as a result of hidden lust.
So, in this kind of case,
you can see that all
around us there are
stories waiting to be told.
And all we have to do is
look for them and understand
that even the myths about
a place really resonate
with that place's history
and where it actually is.
What the place actually feels like.
So, once again, my challenge to
all of you are to find the stories
that are around you and to tell
them, because all of us want
to hear what you have to say.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.